what up guys welcome to the just hurry
things YouTube channel and welcome to
Pearl daily where I cover this week's
treachery debauchery and craziness
before I start don't forget to subscribe
to the channel and ring that
notification Bell that way you're gonna
be notified of my daily videos like the
video on your way in let's get started
so there is
breaking news in the manosphere
the man the myth the legend that has
given dating advice for 20 years
is getting a divorce Steve Harvey is
rumored to be getting a divorce his wife
Marjorie was rumored to be sleeping with
the chef and his personal bodyguard on
top of that it's rumored that she is
trying to take half of his 400 million
dollar Fortune at 200 million
um and so it's interesting because while
this may be a shock to the general
public in the red pill space we Ben saw
this coming oh my gosh we then saw this
like we saw this come in like 10 years
ago because there's a couple red flags
with Marjorie number one
this woman was a single mother and as
much as we harp on single mothers and
you know people think we're just being
mean there is a reason why the red pill
guys and the manosphere guys adamantly
do not advise men to marry single
mothers there's no upside it shows they
have a proven track record of making bad
decisions and there really is no benefit
in marrying a single mother especially a
single mother whose daughter is a hoe
the apple does not fall far from the
tree and if the daughter's probably a
hoe the mom's probably a hoe she learned
it somewhere so let's let's pull the
clip of just some red flags that really
we have seen in the red pill and I'm
going to explain to you why they were
red flags when watching Steve and
marjorie's relationship Dynamics
where did I meet you
tell me first thing I said you I don't
know who this is but I'm gonna marry her
I mean sometimes it's just you got to
get away but you got to look you got to
look for the bright side and everything
and my bright side was her best thing
ever happened to me you know this girl
was like a like like everything for me
you know everything I was missing but
how did you know that she was more than
that
can I tell you something men know
y'all didn't really understand this men
know really we know if you're the one or
you're not all men can change and all
men will change but there's only one
woman that we're going to change for
he's just one
this is how I did it I flew to Cabo
Mexico
so we check into the hotel
she decides she's sleepy she doesn't
want to go to dinner this can't happen
because everything I've worked for is
gonna go down at this dinner so I talked
her into going to dinner I got a private
room inside of a wine cellar in comes
two Waiters with two huge white platters
with silver domes when they open up her
dome it had what looked like
a square piece of gelatin just sitting
there on the plate it was actually a box
and it was cracked
and when she realized that it wasn't
jello
she looked up under there and she said
oh my God and then she started crying
and I opened it up and there was a
rather nice sized diamond I just had a
moment
and that's me and my wife's song too
I met her 86 87 when the song came out
then God gave her back to me in 2005.
I put her name on the back man for you
you understand me
that's mine right there
yeah I own you and you own me
I will kill everybody in here about your
ass please understand that about the way
I love you Marjorie Elaine you
understand me I kill everybody in here I
swear to God you can ask the Lord about
me I'll kill everybody
[Applause]
we asked 100 married women
some days I'd be willing to trade my man
for a really good what
oh boy
what
did you just say
pool boy
thank you
[Music]
he tried it
you know uh my mom always had a phrase
growing up and she would always say
kidding is still half serious there's
some truth when you're joking around and
the fact that this woman had the
audacity to on a public platform
say that
she wants to trade her husband in for a
pool boy
really just shows a lack of respect
right and I I think that's what we see
in a lot of relationships it's like this
egalitarian model where women think it's
okay to publicly disrespect their man
they think it's funny and the issue with
Steve is he puts his woman on a pedestal
she clearly was not checked for a
lifetime
um a couple other red flags that I saw
all men can change but they only change
for the right woman well what does that
mean if the man is changing for the
woman that means she is leading the
relationship again this is just you know
I just personally believe there's a
natural order in the world that goes God
men women children and women need to
follow men and and in a relationship
Dynamic it doesn't work the other way
around you know
um it leads typically to divorce or
typically to the men being basically in
servitude to his woman for a lifetime
the other thing I noticed was he said he
talked her into going to dinner well
what does that tell you that she's
disagreeable like if your boss tells you
to do something you just listen you just
say okay but he has to talk his woman
into going to dinner
and you know I'm not saying we need to
psychoanalyze like every single time in
a relationship but my my whole point is
it really just shows the dynamic of the
relationship meaning they do what she
wants on her terms when she feels like
it
um and he just constantly puts this
woman on the pedestal she is a single
mother who he is putting above him the
man that's worth 400 million dollars
he is implying that the best thing that
ever happened to him was marrying a
single mother
what on Earth does this woman have that
that that is going to make the best
thing in a super accomplished guy's life
a woman and that's the problem in
societies we keep putting women on this
pedestal we keep saying women are the
prize women are the best thing that's
ever happened to us when really men are
the prize
yeah a guy like Steve Harvey many women
are going after
um I'm sorry but who has the leverage in
a relationship the single mother or the
rich comedian let's just call spade a
spade
um the other thing I I noticed Steve
Harvey said was he said I own you and
you own me again this goes back to the
egalitarian model and this is why
um a lot of times we really see
conservatives default to egalitarianism
like we are equal we are the same that's
why when we hear cheating right what is
the default from conservatives well you
know if I say you know we should work
through cheating for the men they'll say
well what about when a woman cheats
should the man stay again that's the
default to egalitarianism when we
covered Twitter erupting because Rachel
said her husband doesn't do chores they
default to egalitarianism and say well
if he loved her he would help well why
can't he help with the chores and again
relationships just work better when
people play their roles when women don't
expect men and to help out with the
domestic work again he said I own you
which is right he's half right and you
own me no no no no no again that that
implies egalitarianism equality and
that's why a lot of more conservative
people are Republican people default to
egalitarianism in their relationships
but they don't even know it so we have
even more you know red flags that the
red pill has seen in Steve Harvey for
years so you know pull up the clips guys
imagine
the audacity
where we have a guy and I know this is
comedy I know it's funny but again
kidding is half serious we've got that
makes millions of dollars every year
takes a care of a hundred percent of the
bills comes home to a wife bitching
about him cleaning when he has a
housekeeper and this is what I mean guys
women we're just never happy don't try
to make a woman happy that's like that's
in our nature we'll just find something
to whine about
now I we can't even help it it's just
like we're just whiners we're big
whiners
um so another another thing I noticed
you you'll see just the lack of General
respect she has for him when she's
deprecating her guy in public you know
the biggest thing two men is respect
respect is love and when you're making
fun of your guy in public that that's
extremely disrespectful another thing
that I thought was ironic how she's
talking about how he's a bad example for
the kids when her daughter is Lori
Harvey
are you kidding like
um and this is the thing
um
even the fact that they had a show
called make over your man I love my man
but
shows just how much he panders and
caters to the female audience it's
always about men having to be better and
never about women improving and this is
something we've seen on TV in the media
in the church it's always about men
being better she's talking about her
needs but doesn't talk for a second
about his how ironic is it that it's
like what else does she do
like she doesn't have to work
so you can't clean like that's that's it
um and this is the thing guys a lot of
single mothers and predatory women will
become experts at making men feel loved
at learning the game just to get what
they want and then get what they want
and cheat later
um and that's why that's why you have
shows like fresh and fit telling you to
sleep with you know 10 20 30 40 50
Chicks before you settle down so you
don't get bamboozled by predatory women
so let me know your thoughts on Steve
Harvey if there's any other Clips you
want me to react to but I think we're
gonna keep seeing um guys that are more
blue pilled in their relationships more
idealistic ending up divorced ending up
cheated on and it's not something I wish
on anybody but the truth of the matter
is there's a natural order in the world
and relationships do not work when it's
out of order
when men put women on pedestals when men
believe that their woman is above them
that is disrupting the natural order of
the world when men give women leverage
because women can't have leverage unless
you give it to them so when men
pedestalize women so much that they give
them leverage it really just messes up
relationships we're going to keep seeing
them fail you know I saw a video from
like 50 years ago of a woman saying my
husband is the boss they said is your
husband the boss she said yes yes
and nowadays
that would be offensive does that woman
seem like she believes her husband's the
boss
does it seemed like he runs that
relationships relationships don't work
when the women run it